let's bring in arizona attorney general
mark bronovich always good to have you
sir i just want to read to you from the
solicitor general this is the biden's
lawyer at the court today and what she
said workers are becoming seriously ill
and dying because they are exposed to
the virus on the job including in
widespread and well-documented workplace
clusters clusters and outbreaks and then
the argument goes on to say if the rule
remains stayed during this winter's
anticipated covet-19 surge hundreds and
potentially thousands of patients may
die at hospitals nursing homes and other
facilities participating in medicare and
medicaid the benefits of requiring
health care workers to be vaccinated far
outweigh any countervailing concerns
mr attorney general
isn't it possible that that can be true
but that still congress didn't give the
authority
to osha or to cms to carry out these
mandates
yeah dana
that's part of the big problem this is
not or a debate about medical science
it is really truly a debate about the
constitution and so someone could be pro
science but you can also be
pro-constitution and nowhere in our
constitution does any president
republican or democrat have this kind of
unfettered authority and discretion in a
time of crisis that's when we need to
uphold the constitution even more
because there's always some
justification some group or some person
is going to say as to why they need to
trample on your individual liberties
but this is when the constitution
becomes most important and that's why
myself and my colleagues are out there
pushing back against the overreach the
bidet administration because this is a
dangerous precedent because no
government should ever tell you or
anyone else that they have to inject
something into their body and so we
shouldn't be discussing whether
experimental vaccine works or not we
should be discussing whether the
constitution is designed to protect our
individual liberty which clearly it is
and specifically attorney general you
know dana brought up a good point
earlier the wall street journal pointed
out look you know the pr presidents and
politicians have this habit of kind of
declaring emergencies when it is
politically you know
to their advantage and what's to stop
president biden from issuing a mandate
or an emergency on climate change or on
you know school loans or something like
that so that's that's really the problem
you're focusing on
yeah absolutely trace i mean there's an
old saying lyndon johnson used to say
that if you let a bully in your front
yard the next day is on your porch and
the day after that he's shacking up with
your spouse but lbj used a different
expression but the point is is that as
we as citizens as we as representative
of our respective states see this
authority of the federal government you
will never get it back and under the
logic of the biden administration they
can literally threaten every single
person's livelihood in this country if
they don't kowtow to the dictates of the
federal government and so what's next in
the future under the guise of healthcare
are they going to tell contractors their
employees can't eat chicago deep dish
pizza are they going to tell you how
much you know caffeine or soda you can
drink every more every morning i mean so
this is really truly a dangerous
precedent this notion that the federal
government under quote-unquote public
health and safety is going to
essentially dictate every single
american that they must do something or
lose their livelihood lose their
benefits lose their life savings it's
just fundamentally unfair it's
unconstitutional as well
do you have thoughts on
the current makeup of the supreme court
being different than in past years
and whether
the conservative position
as your lawsuit states will prevail
my hope is dana i learned a long time
ago and for full disclosure i'm actually
married to a federal judge and i learned
a long time ago not to predict what a
judge is going to do i've handled
thousands of cases in my career but but
i do believe that because the court took
this case on an expedited basis if you
look at the makeup of the court the
judges that have been confirmed over the
last four years especially i mean i
think these are folks that understand
the meaning of the constitution the rule
of law understand you know originalism
and will will make sure that the
constitution's followed because at the
end of the day no president has this
authority and as james madison used to
remind us rights and powers are like two
sides of the same coin and we the people
never ceded this kind of power to the
federal government and in protecting and
trying to push back against this power
overreach by the bite administration we
are protecting all of our individual
rights whether you're a democrat
republican independent and no matter
what state you live in
yeah attorney general great answer thank
you thank you good to see you
we'll see how it goes today thank you